going into the job
I had some experience at a more junior
level of dealing with crises and
emergencies and so I took my
responsibilities
as the
um as the principal responder to a
pandemic very seriously
does dealing with health emergencies
include dealing with infectious diseases
being ready to deal with the risk of
infectious diseases absolutely
so
when concerned in the field of emergency
preparedness
resilience civil contingencies
where there is a health emergency
it is the Department of Health and
Social care that is the lead government
Department in effect it is the
department in the driving seat yes and
as Secretary of State I felt keenly the
responsibility as essentially the lead
responder in the first instance to those
sorts of Health emergencies and it was a
um it was a part of my day-to-day work
because these emergencies happen from
time to time
were when you were Secretary of State
risks prioritized in any way was there a
grading system to prioritize those most
important and and serious risks from
those that were less so yes of course
that's absolutely vital and one of the
challenges in a system as big as the
health system is making sure the
decisions are taken at the right level
because if you escalated everything to
the Secretary of State they whoever they
are they would be completely overwhelmed
yet it's vital to escalate the things
that need to be seen by the Secretary of
State to the uh to their desk
was influenza pandemic prioritized as a
tier one risk yes it was on I recall
that on my first day I was given a
briefing document about as big as this
one
and one of the elements of it was making
clear my responsibility as a as the tier
one National responder for a pandemic
flu and and for other infectious
diseases I was already aware of this
element of the role from my time at the
cabinet office but nevertheless it was
properly informally brought to my
attention and on day one I asked for
more information on preparedness because
I having been involved in previous
crises for instance at the at the bank
of England in before I went into
politics I knew that when things go
wrong things move quickly and you need
to be as well prepared as you can